this program is brought to you by Emory
University
well when we first went through
everything the hardest part about it was
watching someone you love not being able
to do the things that they used to do
like two hours ago
24 hours ago they can do these things
that they couldn't do now they had to
use their arm the leg was kind of they
couldn't really walk you know I sit up
and and you go and you say is my life
gonna be like this the rest of my life
or would it get better
well after you came out of in-house
rehab and then out outpatient rehab
things did get better he came home and
I'm like okay he's home everything's
good but then that's when the panic
attacks set in and I had never had
dealings with them personally myself or
anybody really really close with had
panic attack so I would wake up four
o'clock in the morning and he's not
there and I were it were it they looked
outside he's propped up on the pillows
and on the couch
so nobody had told us about that that
that's part of you know the injury of
the brain and for me I was like panic
attack you know I'm not used to that so
it was it was just weird going through
that it was it was really hard because I
couldn't control even emotion I got the
real emotional which I'm not an
emotional person but you know I'm on a
dime I would go from one end of the
spectrum to another and that was another
thing that I you know I didn't know so I
think everybody concentrate so much on
the physical part but it's a lot of
mental part I go on you know after
stroke that that needs to be addressed
so what I did was what every red-blooded
American does now is go to the Internet
and he can put into symptoms and there
was a doctor that was on TV saying you
know you're having panic attacks this
could be the thing and we have a good
friend of ours who is also a licensed
and clinical counselor we called her
probably about five o'clock in the
morning and he said that is probably
what it sounds like and we did these
breathing exercises kind of calm down
and then right after that we went we
went to the doctor and told him and she
did prescribe something to kind of help
and she was like this is probably
temporary but he'll help me and we saw
an immediate yes I mean he would he
would just be able to cope like a normal
person I mean little things just throw
him over the end he never got the
violence that we've heard about we get
so frustrated you're reaching out and
trying to be you know physical with
somebody he never got that he was on the
other end like the puppy dogs I'm
weeping it you know a leaf is falling in
and crying about it I mean that's not my
husband so with the medication and with
no one what we're dealing with with
doing some research myself and then
talking with some of the doctors we were
able to get a plan together and now he
is kind of like I guess worked itself
out you know you have little ones
sometimes yeah yeah well we have a group
of big group of people or something but
yeah it's a lot lighter now so on
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University